so before 9 11 with Muslims did people
kind of already have a stigma about them
or was it after 9 11 where people were
like this is their fault like this is
their whole religion hates us after 9 11
of course I mean everybody you know you
even looked Muslim people like you were
going to shoot them all run away and and
it's unfortunate it's really very
unfortunate before I never thought about
it I mean it was a horrible thing but
again it's not the everyday people it's
the politicians in their country and
these extremists that are so powerful
they want power and everything else like
that just like Putin wants all this
power and I mean I kind of want to hear
you like where were you online like 9 11
you said you were living in New Jersey
right lived in New Jersey and I worked
after I retired that I went and got a
job and I was in a building in New
Jersey and it was about 10 to 9 in the
morning and I was already at work and
somebody came in and says a plane just
hit the World Trade Center now I could
see the World Trade Center from my
building in New Jersey so of course we
all ran to the window to see the World
Trade Center and a few was it 20 minutes
later we're all standing there we see
another plane coming you saw the second
plane hit yes and we saw the other plane
coming and we all said why is that plane
allowed near there and all of a sudden
Boom the other plane the second plane
went in so you saw the plane hit and
then yes we see the pump what was like
what was going through your head when
you it was horrifying it was horrifying
because we all knew people who worked in
the World Trade Center oh I couldn't
imagine and it was we had family that
worked there yeah I mean it was terrible
I mean everybody knows somebody you know
there's what three thousand people three
four thousand people in that building
you have a mutual of a mutual at least
and that's what happened and I knew
quite a few people unfortunately because
of my business they were my customers
but uh no it was horrifying seeing that
second and then we stood there and then
how many minutes later the buildings
collapsed so you just stood there
continuously watching and until they
fell yeah back then this is before uh we
really cell phones weren't that big you
know I had a cell phone but they weren't
like they are today you didn't get
everything and one of the men in his
office he had a little TV and he brought
it out to the big section and he plugged
the TV in and we were trying to watch on
TV but we had a front row seat yeah we
didn't we were listening to what the
news I think it was Walter Cronkite so
he was a newscaster who was giving the
news you know whatever what was the news
saying right away because I'm pretty
sure the day of they were already like
pinning it on Bin Laden right well I
think the next day once um President
Bush came to the Trade Center he was
wonderful at the time and he talked
about Al Qaeda I didn't know what it was
never heard of it you've never oh you
never heard of Al Qaeda no because I
said we lived in a fancy little
community that we didn't know what was
going on in the outside you know we
heard the news at night but
unfortunately we're guilty of not paying
attention to a lot of it and we heard
that and then you heard Bin Laden you
heard the names I never heard of it
before then wow and it was scary and who
were these people what are they and uh
then of course we all watched every
little thing and it was sad times for
everybody all over the world and then
you heard about the Pentagon and then
Pennsylvania yeah because there were
three planes in three different so what
was it like right after were people like
searching for like their own reasoning
and stuff or was it kind of just like a
believe the media type thing so you
watched the news you saw this person did
it and you're like that's what it is oh
my God it's not kind of crazy to think
about though like you believe but we
didn't know any different yeah what else
what else would you look at I think your
next door neighbor was the person
responsible yeah you know and when we
heard about this you know they bombed
the World Trade Center in 1993 also yeah
on denique because I had cause there at
that point underneath you had caught
limos yeah when it happened parked
outside waiting to pick people up what
had happened what what happened there
like well they bombed the um they failed
uh no they did damage down but I mean
but not like I don't think the intention
was to bring the building down although
I don't think they knew they were going
to bring the building down at 9 11
either well they didn't know they were
bombing it I don't know if they nobody
knew that that building would collapsed
the way that it was so what was the mass
stigma right after 9 11 was it like
because obviously it was Al Qaeda you
know their Muslim group it's their fault
was there anyone else like maybe it was
like more than that let's look deeper
into what the media is just telling us
or there was there wasn't much of a
stigma I think that the mindset wasn't
there to look further that's so crazy to
me Al Qaeda the Muslims you know
whatever and now of course I feel I
think back now people who were Muslim in
America those four people probably had a
hide in their houses because everybody
their Muslims you're no good you're six
year old no you're a future terrorist
and you're this and that it was a very
hard time for the everyday Muslim yeah I
mean I couldn't imagine if you you're a
Muslim and you're you're dressed in your
appropriate clothing and you're just
like going on a train or something it's
like people are like I'm getting the
[ __ ] out of here back then those people
you were people were I mean what I saw
on the television people were afraid to
say get on a subway and you know Muslim
woman or child trusted they were human
beings but they were just as upset and
unhappy as we were and you know there's
bad apples at every group and this was
again Bin Laden and his crew and they're
there and you have this all over the
world look at Putin what were the um
like the first thoughts going through
your head though when you saw that going
down oh my God just the whole world
America especially in New York and that
area I was crying the whole world was
crying first of all the way it happened
and that was such an iconic building
your mom had her first communion party
in that restaurant on Top of the World
Trade Center so it meant oh my God you
know we went there we used to go to the
restaurant there and visit there it was
just unbelievable because nothing
happened ever happened on Iowa soil and
here we were in New York and that's my
backyard you know that happened and it
was just people couldn't didn't dig much
we just were horrified of everything
everybody cried and cried and cried for
yeah you know like what were your
immediate worries for the week after did
you think like something else was about
to happen like or did you I didn't
because you know it's like something bad
a plane crash happens God forbid that
I'll say well I go on and explain it
it's not going to happen again like I
didn't think it would happen again in
that magnitude no yeah you thought
they'd crack down on it we just because
the security since 9 11. yeah I feel I
don't like flying just because I'm
chicken I don't like flying but I never
thought about safety and now I go on
through security in a plane I don't feel
threatened at all that's crazy stuff
though so have you ever looked into any
of like the conspiracy theories or
anything about 911 or you haven't looked
into it much I've heard a lot you know
people talk about it but now I don't
look into it because sometimes you look
too deep into things and your mind
starts working and I'm just a lay person
I'm just yeah you're just like why at
this point why did things like that
happen why would they want to hurt
somebody and that flight that Tuesday
morning it's the same flight number
every week goes out my daughter Aunt
Diane was on that same flight the week
before you know and I says oh my God it
could have been my daughter on that
flight you know you just think of all
different things that would have been
could have been and thank God it wasn't
but it was sad and and only good thing
that came out of it and I don't mean any
good that the country came together it's
interesting that it did for me people
came together everybody was there for
one another consoling one another all
right guys thank you so much for
watching if you're interested in
learning how to make money online and
get some free social media chips tips
check out my Discord we've already had a
bunch of people doing really well so far
so you can start too no reason you can't
also make sure to follow me on Instagram
at sunnyfaz and drop in the comments if
you want more videos with the based
Grandma yeah I'm here
she's got the she can she can come out
whenever we're here in the Florida
Sunshine oh yeah but all right guys
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you later
[Music]
read the writing on the wall won't last
long yeah the feelings
[Music]